>> SPEAKING OF GASES, WE WILL
START TALKING ABOUT THE MEDIA.
WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR A
BRIEFING FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND THE WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE.
INITIALLY THE MEDIA WAS
COMPLAINING ABOUT A LACK OF
THOSE BRIEFINGS.
NOW THEY ARE ALMOST A DAILY
PRESENCE IN YOUR LIFE.
MOMENTUM IS BUILDING TO STOP
AIRING THESE BRIEFINGS.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES":
TRUMP’S BRIEFINGS ARE A RATING
HIT.
SHOULD NETWORKS COVER THEM LIVE?
SOME IN THE MEDIA SAY WE SHOULD
NOT SHOW THEM AT ALL.
>> IF IT WERE UP TO ME AND IT’S
NOT, I WOULD STOP PUTTING
BRIEFINGS ON LIVE TV.
NOT OUT OF SPITE BUT BECAUSE
IT’S MISINFORMATION.
>> THESE BRIEFINGS ARE SUBITUTES
FOR THE RALLIES.
HE KNOWS HE CAN DOMINATE THE
NEWSCAST.
>> TRUMP IS USING THIS AS A
POLITICAL PLATFORM BECAUSE HE
CAN’T HOLD RALLIES RIGHT NOW.
>> HERE’S PRESIDENT TRUMP
CLASHING WITH THE MEDIA.
>> JUST SO YOU UNDERSTAND.
ARE YOU READY?
I THINK THERE ARE CERTAIN PEOPLE
THAT WOULD LIKE IT NOT TO OPEN
SO QUICKLY.
CERTAIN PEOPLE WOULD LIKE IT DO
FINANCIALLY POORLY BECAUSE THEY
THINK THEY WOULD DO GOOD TO
DEFEAT ME AT THE POLLS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN YOUR
PROFESSION THAT RIGHT FAKE NEWS.
YOU DO AND SHE DOES.
NOBODY HAS DONE THE JOB WE IS
DONE.
>> DANA, THE INSANITY IS THEY
DON’T WANT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO HEAR FROM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES LIVE IN THE
GREATIST CRISIS OF OUR LIVES.
THAT’S HOW NUTS THIS IS.
>> YES, I DON’T UNDERSTAND HOW
SOMEBODY’S POLITICAL ANALYSIS OF
THE PRESIDENT’S BRIEFING IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE PRESIDENT’S
BRIEFING.
>> YES.
>> HE IS COMMANDING THE SHIP.
I KNOW THAT A LOT OF THEM DON’T
LIKE IT THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
THE PRESIDENT, BUT HE IS THE
PRESIDENT.
HE IS THE ONE THAT IS ENTRUSTED
IN MAKING DECISIONS THAT HAVE TO
DO WITH OUR LIVELIHOODS AND OUR
HEALTH.
THE THING HE HAS DONE IS
SURROUND HIMSELF WITH PEOPLE AT
THOSE BRIEFINGS THAT TAKE
QUESTIONS.
THEY HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE THIS.
YOU COULD HAVE A BRIEFING THE
LAST 2.5 HOURS.
MAYBE THAT’S PART OF THE
FRUSTRATION.
THEY WANT TO SEE THEIR OWN FACES
ON TV.
THERE ARE A LOT OF GREAT PLACES
INCLUDING FOX NEWS WHERE YOU CAN
GET THE FULL INFORMATION.
IF YOUR LOCAL STATION OR RADIO
DECIDES NOT TO COVER TYOU HAVE A
PLACE TO GO.
>> GREG, TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THESE INDIVIDUALS WOULD RATHER
HEAR THEMSELVES SPEAK THAN A
PRESIDENT PROVIDING INFORMATION
TO ALL AMERICANS WHO CARE ABOUT
THEIR HEALTH AND LOVED ONES.
>> INCOMPETENT PEOPLE FEEL
COMPETITION.
BECAUSE THE COMPETITION EXPOSES
THEIR OWN IDIOCY.
THIS IS NOT A -- THIS ARGUMENT
SHOULD SOUND FAMILIAR TO ANYBODY
WHO WORKED AT FOX.
BECAUSE YOU ARE SUCCESSFUL DON’T
CARE THEM.
IF YOU CAN’T BEAT HIM GET RID OF
HIM.
TRUMP IS A RATINGS WINNER.
THAT’S HOW CNN AND MORNING JOE
ELECTED HIM.
THEY PUT HIM ON THE AIR ALL THE
TIME.
HE BECAME PRESIDENT AND HOW DARE
HE?
THEY SHOULD COVER HIM.
HE IS THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF
DURING A PANDEMIC.
CNN.COM REPORTED ON MEGAN MARK
MARKLE, FOR FORBIDDING HER
HUSBAND FROM VISITING HIS
BROTHER.
>> HE IS THE PRESIDENT.
YOU HAVE TO COVER WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS TO SAY.
HE TURNED THIS INTO THE
POLITICAL RALLY EVENT.
IT’S THE TRUMP SHOW.
EVERY DAY HE GETS A TRUMP SHOW
PLATFORM.
HE DELIVERS A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION.
ASKED HOW HE IS DOING?
HE IS DOING PERFECTLY.
AS PERFECTLY AS THE CALL TO THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT.
>> I SEE WHAT YOU DID.
>> LET ME FINISH.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> HANG ON!
HANG ON, HANG ON A SECOND.
HE SAID THAT.
I DIDN’T SAY THAT.
HE SAID IT WAS AS PERFECT AS HIS
PHONE CALL TO THE UKRAINIANS.
HE SAID WE CAUGHT UP WITH THE
TESTING WITH REGARDING TO SOUTH
KOREA.
SOUTH KOREA IS A MUCH SMALLER
COUNTRY THAN WE ARE.
THEY TESTED LIKE 1 OUT OF EVERY
150 PEOPLE.
WE TESTED 1 OUT OF EVERY 900 AND
WE ARE WAY BEHIND.
HE SAYS THESE THINGS.
PEOPLE COME TO THESE BRIEFINGS
FOR REAL INFORMATION.
THEY ARE GETTING A POLITICAL
PRESENTATION.
I THINK THAT’S WHY A LOT OF
PEOPLE SAY YES, HE IS THE
PRESIDENT.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
WHAT HE IS SAYING.
NOW THE QUESTION ARISES.
AS A JOURNALIST DO WE SAY
WHATEVER HE SAYS IS FINE?
>> NO.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> ARE THE ONLY PERSON LEFT ON
THE EARTH THAT TAKES TRUMP WORD
FOR WORD.
HE IS TRYING TO BE OFT MYSTIC.
-- OPTIMISTIC.
SOMETIMES HE GETS LITTLE THINGS
WRONG BUT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
UNDERSTAND IT.
ONLY THE JOURNALISTS ARE ON
WRONG ON THIS.
THAT’S WHY YOU ARE BEHIND ON THE
REAL STORY.
>> NO.
I THINK THE REAL STORY IS THAT
THE PEOPLE WANT LEADERSHIP.
>> THEY ARE GETTING IT.
>> THAT’S WHY DR. FAUCI -- THEY
ARE NOT GETTING IT FROM TRUMP.
THEY GET IT DR. FAUCI AND
DR. BIRX.
>> IS TRUMP DOING A BAD JOB?
>> HE IS DOING A BANG UP JOB OF
PUTTING ON A TV SHOW THAT GETS
GREAT RATINGS.
>> JUAN, YOU CAN’T ADMIT A
LITTLE BIT.
>> LET JESSE WATTERS GET IN
HERE.
>> THE MEDIA WORRYING ABOUT
MISINFORMATION IS LIKE ABOUT THE
MAFIA WORRYING ABOUT CRIME.
LOOK IN THE MIRROR.
CNN LIVE FOR 2 YEARS.
WE SHOULD TAKE THEM OFF THE AIR!
COME ON.
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TURNED THE
MEDIA INTO C-SPAN.
THEY POINT A CAMERA AND TAKE
LIVE PRESS CONFERENCES.
THEY CAN’T ADD THEIR PUNDITS AND
REPORTERS TO SPIN IT AND PUT
SPECIAL SAUCE AND SERVE IT TO
THE PUBLIC.
THEY GET STUFF WRONG NOW AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE IN THE MOOD
FOR RAW MATERIAL.
THEY DON’T WANT ANYMORE SPIN.
THE MEDIA THINKS THEY ARE
SMARTER THAN THE PRESIDENT.
THEY HAVE TO POINT OUT EVERY
LITTLE TIME THEY THINK THEY ARE
SMARTER AND GOT HIM.
THAT’S NOT TRUE.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC TRUSTS THE
PRESIDENT MORE THAN THEY TRUST
THE MEDIA.
THEY LIKE HIM MORE.
AND IT’S BECAUSE HE IS MORE
COMPELLING.
HE IS MORE HONEST AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD.
THAT’S THE TRUTH.
WHEN HE GOES UP THERE, YOU ARE
NOT ONLY GETTING REAL
FACE-TO-FACE REALITY.
YOU ARE GETTING A MAN THAT IS
ENTERTAINING.
THAT CAN SPEAK IN SOLID GOLD
SOUND BITES THAT EVERY AMERICAN
CAN UNDERSTAND.
THEY ARE JEALOUS OF HIM.
THEY DON’T HAVE ANYBODY ON THOSE
NETWORKS THAT CAN COMPETE WITH
THAT KIND OF TALENT.
THEY DON’T HAVE IT IN HOLLYWOOD
OR CNN.
THEY DON’T HAVE ANYWHERE.
INSTEAD OF WORKING IMPROVING
THEIR PERFORMANCE, THEY ARE
TRYING TO CENSOR THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
HOW INSANE IS THAT?
IF YOU WANT TO FACT CHECK HIM,
JUAN, FACT CHECK HIM AFTERWARDS
WHEN YOU HAVE THE 13 LITTLE
BOXES ON THE SCREEN LIKE WE DO.
BUT DON’T CUT HIM OFF IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PRESS CONFERENCE.
>> HE IS TRYING TO WASTE OUR
TIME AND IMPOSE HIMSELF ON THE
NEWS CONFERENCE.
>> THIS IS THE AMERICAN PEOPLE’S
TIME.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> YOU HAVE A POLITICAL LEADER
WHO IS SPOUTING AT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, IS THAT PROPAGANDA?
>> REPORTERS ARE ASKING GREAT
QUESTIONS AND WE ARE GETTING
GREAT ANSWERS AND THE TASK FORCE
SAID I DIDN’T THINK I THOUGHT
ABOUT IT THAT WAY.
AND THEY DELIVER MORE NEWS THE
NEXT DAY.
IT’S HELPING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> WHEN THE PRESIDENT TWEETED
AROUND 5 O’CLOCK HE WOULD BE ON
AROUND 5:10 AND THEY WILL FOCUS
ON THE QUESTION OF THE WHAT ARE
THE GUIDELINES GOING TO BE THAT
WILL TELL PEOPLE, LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND COMPANIES AND
WORKERS.
PEOPLE WANT TO TUNE INTO THAT.
WHAT ARE THE GUIDELINES?
HOW WILL WE GET PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK AND DO THIS RESPONSIBLY AND
WITH SENSITIVITY AND WITH
TECHNOLOGY?
IT’S POSSIBLE THAT WE ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO ADD THIS FINGER
PRICK TEST TO TELL PEOPLE YOU
AND YOU ARE IMMUNE AND CAN GO
BACK TO WORK OR LIKE IN SOUTH
KOREA WHERE YOU GET YOUR
TEMPERATURE TAKEN BEFORE YOU ARE
ALLOWED INTO THE WORKPLACE OR A
SHOP TO BUY GROCERIES.
I WILL PROVIDE INFORMATION THAT
IS VITAL.
I CAN’T IMAGINE PEOPLE NOT
WANTING TO TAKE THIS PRESS
CONFERENCE COMING UP.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF THE
PRESIDENT LAYING OUT HOW WE ARE
GOING TO GET BACK TO WORK IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY.
>> THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
SHUT THE PEOPLE DOWN WHO LIED
ABOUT RUSSIAN COLLUSION FOR
YEARS.
AND NOW THEY ARE PLAYING DOCTOR
ON TELEVISION.
THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
AGAIN, THEY LEARNED THEIR
MEDICAL KNOWLEDGE FROM FLETCH.
THAT’S HOW SMART THEY ARE.
>> FLETCH, THAT’S A THROW BACK.
>> YEAH.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE BRIEFING
WILL START ANY MOMENT NOW.
STAY WITH US.
IN THE MEANTIME.
HOSPITALS IN THE OUTBREAKS
EPICENTER IN NEW YORK CITY IS
BEING OVERWHELMED WITH COVID-19
CASES.
IN THAT STATE THEY TOP 37,000
PEOPLE.
A SINGLE HOSPITAL IS REPORTING
13 DEATHS IN 24 HOURS.
DOCTORS ARE WARNING OF
APOCALYPTIC CONDITIONS AND
HEALTHCARE WORKERS SAY THEY
DON’T HAVE ENOUGH PROTECTIVE
GEAR.
NURSES FORCED TO WEAR TRASH BAGS
TO KEEP THEMSELVES SAFE.
IN BOSTON, LOCAL NEWS OUTLETS
REPORTING MORE THAN 100
HEALTHCARE WORKERS HAVE THE
VIRUS.
THIS IS SPREADING INTO AREAS OF
THE COUNTRY NOT PREVIOUSLY HIT.
IN NEW ORLEANS, THEY ARE HAVING
A SURGE OF VIRUS CONFIRMATIONS.
HOW DO YOU TAKE THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK IT’S SHOWING
WHAT DR. FAUCI AND DR. BIRX HAVE
TOLD US IS COMING TRUE.
WE KNOW THAT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING IS HAVING AN IMPACT
TO TRY TO SLOW THE RATE OF THE
PEOPLE THAT NEED
HOSPITALIZATION.
ONE REASON IT TAKES THE
PRESIDENT’S BRIEFING YESTERDAY,
HE ANNOUNCED HE IS ALLOWING THE
MAJOR DISASTER DECLARATION FOR
LOUISIANA BECAUSE THAT ALLOWS
FUNDS TO GET THERE FOR WHAT THEY
WILL NEED.
DIFFERENT STATES ARE GOING TO
HAVE DIFFERENT PROBLEMS.
LOUISIANA ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
WAS BIG PARTIES AT MARDI GRAS.
THAT’S A DENSE SITUATION.
IN WYOMING, WHERE MY FAMILY IS
FROM, IT’S NOT THERE YET AND
IT’S NOT OVERWHELMING THE
SITUATION YET, BUT THAT GOVERNOR
ALSO ORDERING STAY AT HOME.
YOU CAN HOPEFULLY START TO SEE
AFTER THIS BRIEFING WHAT IS THE
OTHER SIDE LOOK LIKE?
IT’S GOING ACCORD TO HOW DR.
FAUCI AND DR. BIRX TOLD THE
PRESIDENT FROM THE BEGINNING IT
WOULD GO.
>> JESSE, WHAT ABOUT THE
HOSPITAL WORKERS.
THEY DON’T HAVE THE PROPER GARB
SO THEY ARE PUTTING ON GARBAGE
BAGS.
DO THE NURSES AND THE DOCTORS
AND ALL OF THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE
THINGS HAPPEN AT THE HOSPITALS
KEEP GOING TO WORK?
OR DO SAY THEY WE CAN’T HANDLE
IT?
>> I HOPE THEY DON’T STOP GOING
TO WORK.
THAT’S THE BEST WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW.
JUAN.
GOVERNOR CUOMO SAID THEY HAVE
ENOUGH EQUIPMENT RIGHT NOW FOR
THE HOSPITAL.
YOU HAVE SEEN PEOPLE WITH THAT
TYPE OF GARB.
I SPOKE TO A GUY TODAY WHO IS A
DOCTOR AT CORNELL MEDICAL IN NEW
YORK CITY.
HE SAID HE IS CONFIDENT NOW.
HERE’S WHY.
HE KNOWS HOW TO NOT GET
CORONAVIRUS.
HE IS ON THE 41 LINES.
-- FRONT LINES.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST MISTAKES YOU
CAN MAKE IS TOUCHING YOUR FACE.
HE SAID IF YOU DO EVERYTHING TO
AVOID TOUCHING YOUR FACE, THAT’S
THE NUMBER 1 WAY TO TRANSMIT
SOMETHING.
I TOUCH SOMEONE OR TOUCH A
SURFACE AND YOU FOR A SMALL ROOM
WITH SOMEONE WHO IS INFECTED AND
YOU TOUCH YOUR FACE.
THAT’S THE NUMBER 1 WAY THIS
THING IS TRANSMITTED.
YOU HAVE TO STOP TOUCHING YOUR
FACE.
YOU HAVE TO CARRY PUREELL
EVERYWHERE.
EVERYBODY WHO IS SOCIAL
DISTANCING CAN STAY CLEAN.
THAT’S HOW WE WILL SOLVE THIS
EVENTUALLY.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> ONE OF MY FRIENDS IS WORKING
IN AN EMERGENCY ROOM.
THEY THINK HE GOT DOUBLE
PNEUMONIA FROM CORONAVIRUS
SEVERAL WEEKS AGO.
THEY ARE PUTTING THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE TO SAVE NEW YORKERS.
THEY WOULD DO IT FOR EVERYONE
SINGLE AMERICAN.
NEVER FORGET THAT.
>> A VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION.
WHO ARE THE PATIENTS THAT ARE
DYING
DYING?
THEY WERE PREVIOUS HEALTHY?
DID THEY RECEIVE ANY OF THE
DRUGS AND THE ANTIBIOTICS.
HAS BEEN ANYBODY DIED FROM THAT
DRUG?
I HAVE NOT HEARD IT.
I HEARD FROM DOCTORS WHEN YOU
GET THAT DRUG, YOU GET BETTER.
DEMAND THAT IT.